whoa
isn't it just crazy that you're in the
cast and you're in this hit show
I guess is it crazy for you I'm not even
here you have to answer some questions
I'm the interviewer that's not correct
episode 2 Harper and Ethan have dinner
with Cameron and Daphne and they get
into a conversation about having kids
and I think it kind of catches them off
guard a little bit do you want to have
kids
uh yeah yeah they kind of touch a nerve
without realizing by asking us about
like our sex life and where we're saying
I know we're fine we do it you know
enough like we think we're good and then
by the end of dinner I'm like oh maybe
we're not problem is I'm more of a
morning sex guy and the Harper is not a
morning person yeah makes sense I don't
want to make this like a therapy session
for us okay um I would say the root of
the tension between Harper and Ethan in
my opinion and sweetheart you can say
whatever you want but there's like this
underlying resentment that is kind of
building towards Ethan for her why are
you threatened by them I'm not I was
just trying to say that I think we have
a good relationship but I won't do that
again this is like this false belief
that if you go on vacation or you leave
your life with all your problems behind
and it's you actually just are the same
person living the same life all your
problems go with you it doesn't matter
what the view is you're never going to
be happy Aubry
how'd you guys like being rich okay my
God come on it probably affects your
sense of self uh to have recently come
into a lot of money like I don't feel
like that's what the problem is with
Ethan and Harper I almost feel like
they're exactly how they were when they
didn't have as much money except they're
in like a different place with different
people and maybe that's like the
Catalyst for all the other stuff to kind
of bubble out I had to have an emergency
cesarean they have these guts are all
over the table you know Daphne and
Cameron have this like really tender
moment about their kids and I think it's
like the first time that Harper feels
like maybe I've really judged them
harshly it's in those moments you
realize just how much you love somebody
you know
I love you and also maybe they have it
all figured out and I'm just some stuck
up [ __ ] that
has a dick up my ass can I say that on
HBO yeah
[Music]
I would pick Tanya to go on vacation
with because she's drunk the whole time
and it's kind of fun she's fun and
people that have that kind of chaotic
energy it is soothing to me because it
feels like all the drama is over there
she seems like watching the show like
who would kind of make friends because
she seems to be traveling on her own
quite a lot
[Music]
my go-to vacation drink is the apparel
Spritz I mean especially in Italy I
don't think I've had one since really no
what are you trying I don't know why
some wine
I love carrying on yeah God there's
nothing that gets me going if you can
carry it all up more than carrying on a
tiny little [ __ ] suitcase zipping
right through the airport and just
flipping off all the people in the
baggage claim when you go for this trip
no I brought a lot of clothes that I
never wear yeah for some reason I think
I kind of panic packed
I'm not really inconsistent about my
wake-up times but on vacation it depends
on how much I drank the night before
some Italian Prosecco no thanks
I have small children so I'm pretty
early you do
how am I just finding out now
[Music]